[Music]
I want to wish all my Indian fans happy
Diwali so living in Malaysia I enjoy a
huge variety of indica since I love the
intense flavours spiciness and richness
of the dishes well unfortunately Indian
foods tend to get a bad rap of being
unhealthy this impression about Indian
food exists is because most restaurants
and takeaways tend to serve us with huge
portions of greasy and healthy and
calorie dense meals so guys we all know
that whether a food is healthy or
unhealthy really comes down to the
preparation cooking methods and also the
portion size so the next time you were
to cook or eat Indian foods here are few
tips to make it healthier pack on the
spices the best way to flavor your food
with the adding extra calories is to use
lots of Hertz and spices so experiment
and use a huge variety of spices go easy
on the oil and coconut milk Indian
curries are well-known for the
creaminess and oiliness try to use a
nonstick pan and reduce the amount of
oil used yes coconut milk is very
healthy and flavorful however it is
still very high in saturated fat just
half a cup of coconut milk has about 278
calories and 28 grams of fat so you want
to really reduce the amount use avoid
cream based stews or curries so swap it
for yogurt instead and go for tomato
based curries choose grill over deep
frying so avoid deep fried foods such as
pakoras samosas onion bhaji vada or even
fried chicken choose anything tangerine
which is essentially grilled food choose
plain rice over flavored rice most
flavored rice such as Brioni rice tends
to be loaded with ghee or oil so for
instance one cup of cooked Brioni rice
has about 350 calories and 10 grams of
fat whereas one cup of cooked basmati
plain rice
has less than 200 calories don't overdo
it on rice I'm sure we all know someone
who would pile on a huge amount of rice
on their plate remember guys rice should
only make up quarter of your meal and
finally be wise about bread a nun goes
perfectly with curry but be aware that
one piece of plain nun has about 247
calories butter or cheese nun can
sometimes rack up to 400 calories so
choose lighter option and go for chapati
instead which only has 100 calories per
piece so follow these tips and you can
enjoy Indian foods as part of a healthy
and balanced diet so I wanna share with
you some of my favorite Indian dishes
which you can have for breakfast lunch
and dinner guys I have to be honest and
say that it can be quite intimidating to
cook Indian food because of the huge
varieties of spices used and also it can
take quite long to prepare a dish so
what I'm going to share with you is my
take on some of my favourite Indian
dishes I've recreated them to make them
healthier and you can prep these dishes
in under 30 minutes so it's quick easy
and convenient for breakfast I love
steamed idli instead of the traditional
method we want to add oats and
vegetables into the mixture to make it a
really filling breakfast what you'll
need are 3/4 cup of oats grinded into
powder 3/4 cup of rubber 3/4 cup of
yogurt half a cup of water 1 small
carrots grated half a teaspoon of baking
soda 1/2 a teaspoon of mustard seeds 2
green chilies finely chopped 1 tsp of
curry leaves finely chopped about 6 to 7
crushed cashew nuts 1/2 a tbsp of canola
oil and half a teaspoon of salt so in a
large bowl add oats rava and salt mix
well then add in the yogurt and mix
until well combined set aside heat 1/2 a
tbsp of oil over medium-high heat add in
the mustard seeds cashew nuts green
chillies and curry leaves saute very
quickly until they begin to pop
and stir in the grated carrots and
continue to saute for another 1 to 2
minutes remove from heat add the cooked
mixture and half a cup of water into the
oats rava batter combine well grease
each lipids with a little bit of oil if
you don't have it just use 8 small
stainless steel cups just like what I'm
doing here and right before steaming mix
in the baking soda scoop the batter
equally into the cups steamed for about
12 to 15 minutes and serve warm I like
to have 2 idlis for breakfast with a
side of light chutney or down so rava is
made from durum wheat which has a higher
protein content and it's digested slowly
oats on the other hand is known for its
high fiber content so the combination of
rava oats and carrots will keep you
fuller for longer and prevent overeating
these eglise are hiding cups and protein
below in fat so they also make a great
pre-workout snack to boost your energy
and performance level as for lunch I'm
going to show you how to make my mango
spinach down so what I've used are 1/2 a
cup of yellow lentils soaked and drained
1 ripe mango peeled and diced 1 cup of
spinach washed and chopped 3 cups of
water 1/2 a medium onion diced 2 garlic
cloves minced 1/2 a tablespoon of ginger
minced quarter teaspoon of ground
coriander quarter teaspoon of ground
turmeric quarter teaspoon of cumin seeds
quarter teaspoon of cayenne pepper half
a teaspoon of salt divided and half a
tablespoon of canola oil in a pot add 2
cups of water lentils turmeric and
quarter teaspoon of salt bring to a boil
then reduce to a simmer and allow it to
cook for about 15 minutes remember to
stir occasionally so while waiting for
the lentils to cook in a pan heat 1/2 a
tablespoon of oil over medium high heat
add cumin seeds and cook very quickly
for about 30 seconds until fragrant and
slightly Brown then stir in the onion
and cook for another 1 to 2 minutes
until
onions are golden brown and fragrant
stir in the rest of the ingredients
garlic ginger coriander cayenne pepper
and the remaining quarter teaspoon of
salt continue to saute very quickly for
another one minute removed from heat
stir in the cooked mixture mango and
spinach into the lentils allow all the
ingredients to simmer for another 15
minutes
until the lentils are falling apart
remember to keep stirring occasionally
serve warm this dish is bursting with
flavors I love the nutty and earthy
flavor of the lentils combined with the
sweetness of mango and the spices really
brings this dish together for a balanced
meal serve it with 1:02 chapatis or one
cup of cooked basmati rice lentils is
also a great source of protein for
vegetarians so if you have never tried
lentils before it is time to add
vegetable food into your diet and of
course a for dinner we have to cook
curry I mean what is Indian food without
curry what you'll need our help
a can of chickpeas rinsed and drained
one and a half cups of cauliflower
florets half an eggplant cut into 1-inch
chunks half a can of diced tomatoes
about 3/4 cup of water half a large
onion sliced 1 garlic clove minced 1 TSP
of fresh ginger minced 1 tablespoon of
curry powder half a teaspoon of garam
masala 1/2 a teaspoon of mustard seeds
quarter teaspoon of salt and 1
tablespoon of canola oil divided in a
pot heat 1/2 a tbsp of oil over
medium-high heat add curry powder garam
masala mustard seeds taught very quickly
until the spices begin to darken then
add onion garlic ginger and salt saute
for about 1 to 2 minutes until they are
soft and slightly brown then stir in the
eggplants chick peas cauliflower
tomatoes and water cover and cook for
about 15 minutes until vegetables are
tender remember to stir occasionally
remove from heat and serve warm one
serving only has
225 calories so serve it with half a cup
or one cup of rice and even a piece of
chicken or fish this makes a really
wholesome and delicious meal
so all these recipes can be prepped
ahead and they will keep well in the
fridge for up to three days or in the
freezer for up to two weeks the bottom
line is no matter what Cozine it is
there will always be the healthier and
also unhealthy options make smarter
choices choose healthier cooking methods
such as grilling boiling steaming baking
or lightly stir frying if you're used to
eating huge portions start being aware
of your portion size and remember to
stay active on a daily basis ok so these
are few of my favorite in-game dishes
what are your favorites let me know in
the comments below don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up share it and
subscribe to my youtube channel for new
weekly videos and also for more healthy
recipes all the best
you